indeed we saw irina blunder a piece
earlier come back now like a star we saw
carissa
get outplayed come back it looks like
the cream is starting to rise to the top
arena a great game by you here in the
kind of style i think you like just
domination yeah that's true maurice i do
feel really happy about this game um it
just feels good to play good moves you
know and to and definitely there were
these ideas of domination uh in this
game like the total control of the
center by white
um and i got to play this kind of um
pretty move rook d5 offering up an
exchange in the middle of the game that
was pretty cool and i got to show you
guys there was um there were some tricks
that i needed to avoid in this game i
don't know if you guys caught it for
example when she played this move rook
d8 um
yeah a little bit later a little bit
later yeah a bit later
so here we go um
yeah so here was the exchange sack it
was kind of cool you know because knight
c3 queen d3
uh knight d5 queen d5 i had to calculate
that of course but you know the thing is
yeah again the centralization theme
comes up and i am going to win
this night with like a 96 94 combination
of those moves so i thought that was
pretty uh good for me because she
doesn't have queen c6 here and queen
eight there's knight d6
[Music]
and
after and then knight d4
our main main defense for her was rookie
eight um and erita what what had you
prepared uh i guess knight d6 96 and
okay
seven was i mean you have queen d7 here
yeah what did i for some reason 27 just
take on the eight and then i also said
knight of five ideas queen d actually
knight d4 queen d7 knight of five is
actually really uh pretty this was our
main map no just
b6 yeah i was actually going to do the
other night can i do the other night
oh i don't know yeah i was going to do
this night
kind of stylish that might be it
because she can't to go rookie eight so
you know it seems a little bit of a
problem because that queen hangs it's
like king f7
is forest but that leaves that loses at
least a pawn looks like after knight
decent i think c7 takes rook and the
knight takes on e6
yeah yeah
at least okay okay this is a nice queen
end game yeah
unless there was something even more
snappy but well that's enough but you
had you had foreseen all of these nice
tricks yeah i mean i find because you
know it's funny because after 94 was
really a critical moment and to be
honest i thought about the move rook c1
and of course it's a bit of a lame move
but i thought well maybe my advantage is
so big i can do this and then go like
knight f3 to d4
but then i was like no i should go back
and take a closer look at rook d5 and
see if i can just make it work um but
okay the nice tricks for her are coming
up so she after rook d5 she went rogue
d8 and so here i thought i was just
doing great and she surprised me with
this move um
oh i'm sorry oh yes no no rook d8 yeah
let me show you after rook dean instead
of knight d4 so here's the trick rook d
was surprising because i was like wow i
have very appealing rook takes d8 and
then followed by queen d3 or queen d3
immediately and then you know you don't
want the game to end with queen a1 king
h2 and queen h1
yeah yeah that was so devious i mean
shades of max irva versus alexander
alechem
nice and she has the same trick on queen
d3 so yeah i had to really watch out for
that and i was quite aware of those
tactics for the rest of the game
nice very instructed
all right so that is what drew you to
the move knight d4 once you saw queen h1
land you got no no i'm gonna put my
queen on the g4 square yeah i really
love that knight on d4 i mean just uh
all the pieces in the center yeah those
knights are just monsters if kenny
bariev once wrote an article in new in
chess magazine where he explained when
he was playing against karpov and
kasparov
their knights moved differently than his
knights and that's what this felt like
it felt like your knights
had more powers
than her knights and your move f4
actually that was really a powerful move
too yeah i think in the end this f4 king
h2 idea like i was also happy with that
just you know
like a pretty soft touch you know king
h2 a little bit of prophylaxis there and
you threatened queen g4 and yeah i had
seen that she couldn't move her queen uh
because of queen b5 so
i mean okay like i think the the center
pawns are just more valuable than the
queen side pawns in this game
wonderful
queenside queenside pawns never
got going
karissa won a big game i'm looking back
for your game and finish here carissa
won a big game last year
it was online tournament and
you took the lead she took the lead you
took the lead and it was like bouncing
back before you searched at the end it's
starting to look a little bit like that
right now
yeah you know well i'm focused on my
tournament worries you know there's
still four games to play
and um yeah i feel good about about this
game and hopefully i can just keep up
this level of play that's important all
right congratulations and good luck the
rest of the way thank you
congratulations arena big victory for
every time checking in on